okay you know what actually i wanted to
give a special shout out to my kids
grandparents
ari and koko kobelman that's right
um i love them so much
and it was ari's birthday this week so
we've been doing a lot of celebrating
of poppy and that's grammy and
i have to tell you they told me that
they've been watching the show and they
are supremely honest with me like when
ari doesn't get something he just flat
out says it and which is great because i
always know where i stand with them
and they're worldly and i really trust
their opinion and taste and honestly
i want to make them proud and they're
loving the show so
hi guys i love you now
do we have any grandparents in our vff's
today
joyce hi how are you drew
hi joyce how are you
ari always says there's nothing
overrated about being a grandparent
that's one of his famous questions he's
the kind of guy too who everywhere he
goes he walks around and he goes
isn't this the best it's the greatest
thing
so i call them grammy and poppy do you
have a grandparent nickname
i do my grandchildren alexandra and
branson they call me mimi
i asked to be called ramsay but they
call me mimi so
one happy me me am i well there were
definitely pre-existing family members
who chose grammy and poppy so i was just
lucky to get on the train and i'm so
glad to meet you joyce and thank you for
sharing
my little mimi song
well congratulations on being an
excellent grandparent
congratulations on you thank you joyce
all right we've got a big show
today helping me close out our second
show of the week is a wonderful
sweet kind and very funny friend of mine
we were also married once his name is
tom green and
um you know it's a
it's a moment i'm excited to show it
with you share it with you
all right and we want to shine a light
on all the wildflowers out there all the
girls and women who are breaking down
walls and making their own paths to
success
and today we meet skye brown who is a
young skateboarder and
she is so brave and man she's about to
tell us something that
trust me you just don't want to miss it
it blew my hair back so
let's first get into some information
about the world we live in
it's time for some drew's news
sir ma'am guy ma'am
i asked you a question
[Music]
it's drew's news
all right let's see what made the papers
first okay this is actually
sort of uh you know a very important
periodical to me growing up
tv guide has a section called cheers and
jeers
and i even talked to a journalist
recently and was like cheers and jeers
it's like you know it's still
out there and it's in the latest issue
of tv guide and this week
guess what guys i'm so excited to share
this with everyone here
our show made the cheer section
phew oh my gosh
i'm not kidding i uh phew
we they uh damian holbrook said that we
had a divinely inspired
launch i mean this is such a big deal
for me when i was a kid i would savor my
tv guides and i
always looked to the chairs and jeers
for what was like
good or couldn't be missed and it's a
tradition that's still going on i'm not
getting i check in regularly about it
so cheers right back at you damien and
tv guide thank you for
the props it means a lot to us
so i'm so excited for this news i just
saw father of the bride's
gang is getting back together today
netflix is dropping father of the bride
then we'll call it part three
steve martin diane keaton kimberly
williams paisley martin short
kieran culkin and nancy meyers the
writer director herself they're all back
and the reunion is benefiting
world central kitchen who happens to be
with
friend of the show jose andres
that's right changing the world he is
and a fun fact i have the dvd
in our really old ancient minivan and i
play the movie for the kids all the time
and to this day
i get very verklempt every time steve
martin is doing his voiceovers because
obviously i can't be watching while i'm
driving but
i hear him talking about the house they
grew up in and how it's like
cool in the summer and warm in the
winters and anytime you hear a father
talking about their daughter this way i
mean i'm just telling you
oh it's so good so i'm gonna be checking
that out maybe
you can too okay i don't mean to stress
you out
but we're almost a month away from
halloween
have you thought of a costume have you
thought of one for your guinea pig
well don't freak out yet because pop
sugar has posted a guide to petsmart's
fun and affordable costumes
for all your furball friends oh you
don't have a guinea pig oh you don't
care
well we're gonna look at all these
photos anyway all right first step for
our traditional
here's a lovely pumpkin boy oh hi
pumpkin boy
there you are oh yeah and then there's
unicorn princess look at her
and there's also a bumblebee and
a lobster and a baby dino look at these
cuties
oh and here's one more costume i wanted
to show you guys
oh there you are hi
i'm telling you we we're running wild
kingdom at my house
like my kids are always like you know
especially olive's nickname is literally
ace ventura
we're actually gonna do a segment called
dr drew little because
let's face it when your kids get pets
you get pets all right so
this one i got the hot dog by the way
this is daisy
she's a boy
and uh yeah so we're gonna turn daisy
into a wiener
condiments whole all the fun in the
world daisy thank you so much
you're just the best thank you daisy yes
give it up for daisy